Countryside and wildlife:...
...few combinations make such harmonious companions.
And frolicking otters on the UK's riverbanks are just a perfect example.
But otters in fish ponds are not so harmonious.
This video, titled "Fish Under Attack," shows one devious mammal making off with a huge haul.
Having installed a video camera to find out who was stealing fish,...
...this couple caught the culprit red-handed.
Not before he made off with 39 prized fish.
Further investigation shows it's not just otters that are a bit handy.
Video evidence reveals that raccoons are just as light-fingered.
Mats, rugs, or scraps of carpet within easy reach of cat flaps are rich pickings for this serial snare.
And it isn't just land-based mammals with a penchant for pocket picking.
Gray seals happy to look their victim in the eye before making a getaway.
Reports have also emerged of vanity crime.
The perpetrators usually come across as charming as a ruse to make off with your bling.
But it's not just the call of the wild that leads to criminal instincts.
Coolheaded cat burglars could be inside your house.
You have been warned.